hello everyone and welcome back to the
feed a grand prix it's a game between
Boris Gelfand and the young upon Russia
two of the classical games between the
two of them have been wrong and this is
the second game of the rapid the first
game was won by Knepper and now Boris
needs a win with the white pieces to get
back in the in the match before we check
out the game I would just like to ask
you one question I've been contacted by
the elite chess team they asked if I was
interested in joining their new it's
called team battles so for example we
form a team let's say if let's say a
hundred of you are interested we form a
team we name the team and then we enter
the team battles and then I don't know
maybe Jerry from chess network will form
a team maybe I know a Eric Rosen will
form a team and then we're gonna have
it's a new mode I have no idea how it
works but I will put a link to it in the
description below where you can read up
about it if you're interested and if you
wanna join our team which still doesn't
exist but if you if some of you guys
will be interested we can form a team
and then we can participate to see if
you know maybe it's gonna be fun and
basically now the way it works is let's
say there are teams of 50 players or
maybe 100 players and then only the like
if the team has 100 players only the
scores from the 20 players who do the
best account so not the scores of all
100 people count but only of those who
do best but I think it can be decided up
front where it will be the top 10 scores
top 20 scores top 50 scores like I said
it's a it's a new thing unleashes so if
you guys are interested I will put a
link to it the first thing you will see
in the description below or read up
about it and if you're interested I will
pin my own comment asking whether you're
interested and then you can just you
know leave a like or say I'm interested
and maybe you can even suggest a name
for our team so that being said let's
check out the game and also we have this
very nice photo courtesy of Nicky Riga
official photographer of the feeder
Grand Prix there you have it Napo
against Boris Gelfand it's from the game
where nappa had the white pieces but
still just so you get in the mood you
can see that nipple still is rockin his
bond and board is looking good
always so let's check out the game Boris
with the white pieces opens with Knight
to f3
so the ready opening is on the board we
have Knight to f6 C for that and g6 nepo
prepares the Finca to the dark square
Bishop Knight to c3 and now Bishop g7
with E for and here the well-known pawn
sacrifice with E 5 it's only a temporary
pawn sacrifice but it results in some
excellent game and it's a really
interesting line especially for a rapid
game so Knight captures an e5 nipple
castles and now there are no moves in
this position Bishop to e2 in the knight
to f3 but Boris goes for f4 he needs to
win this game so he can't afford really
to play passive moves and it is already
as of move six that we have a completely
new game so these six by napalm pushes
the knight back Knight to f3 and now
Knight captures on e4 this is how you
win back the pawn even though it's a
temporary piece sacrifice with Knight
captures on e4 and now rook e8 pinning
the knight the next move you're gonna
capture it well like this so b3
defending and now just f5 attacking the
pinned piece there should be dude
there's no way of saving the night with
F captures D captures on e4 and now
Knight to a6 by nipple going for rook
captures on e4 is impossible due to
Queen d5 check picks up the rook or you
can just bring the rook back but then
Knight g5 again attacks the pin piece
and you don't have c6 to kick away the
Queen because just Knight captures and
the next move you're gonna capture black
queen as well so we have Knights the
aces by nipple the knight is now coming
to c5
we have castles and knights to c5 and
excellent square for the knight
you can not kick it away due to the rook
being hanging on a one so f5 Boris
starts the attack G captures an f5 and
now Knight to g5 like I said Boris needs
a win and he's going all out here and
now we have Queen to e7 by Napo it's
important to keep an eye on the e6
square for example if you play something
like night chapters on e4 again Queen d5
check is deadly and now you don't really
have a good move you can start giving up
pieces or you just run into a smothered
mate after Knight f6 check
for those of you who are perhaps new to
chess I will just show what a smothered
mate is so King g8 now you deliver a
double check here with the knight and
the Queen if you go here then Queen to
f7 is mate so you have to go to a trade
and now you sacrifice the Queen rook
characters is the only move and now
Knight the f7 is a nice smothered mate
so you know danger lurks all around with
Queen t7 grabbing more control of d6
Square and now Bishop to h5 pushing the
rug back rook to f8 and now Queen d5
check we have a Bishop to e6 blocking
and now Knight captures on e6 and now
you cannot capture right away if you
recapture just pawn captures attacks the
pin piece and you lose a piece and it's
game over you could capture with the
Queen but still it captures an f5 is
very strong Queen captor Sundy 5c
captors on d5 and well white is just up
upon in a in a in an endgame where he
also has the bishop pair so it's a it's
a really good position for white so
instead we have c6 by nipple pushes a
Giffen screen away but elephant
continues with Bishop g5 there is no
turning back here here we have Queen
captures on g5 now again offering the
Queen for see captors on d5 we have
Queen captures on c5 now eliminating the
night so a lot of Queens hanging for a
very long time and now if D captures on
c5 and then just knife captors and g5
white is up a piece of course completely
winning so Knepper goes back queenie 7
and this is how we win back the piece
now the white queen has to move Queen
back to f2 and then out comes Queen
captures on e6 just grabbing that piece
now with a captures on f5 and then now
Queen captures on c4 so the material is
equal and nipple threatening Bishop d4
to win the Queen so King h1 and napadas
the same king to h8 you don't want your
King on this well exposed diagonal and
now Queen to g3 yeah if you try
something like rook 8 you want not waste
time black might even grab a pawn you
could go rook the e6 hope to execute f6
at some point but it's
it's a really tough tough position to
play especially for girlfriend who is
very low on time also the B to point is
now hanging the bishop protects that as
well so white doesn't have time for
something like this so instead against
one goes for Queen to g3 puts pressure
on the d6 pawn and now Bishop to e5 just
pushing the Queen away Queen to h3 now
rook the f6 and now Bishop g6 preparing
to deliver checkmate with Queen captures
in h7 now Queen back to g8 the only good
move for nipple and now comes Luke 81
still get on it was very long time here
and this is a very tricky move the the
crucial line to define here is G for g4
and now if Queen to d5 check it's not a
problem just rook f3 and the Queen has
to go back because Queen captures on h7
will be checkmate
so here after g4 you would have to go
rook back to faith because g5 is coming
you're gonna push g5 and now you just
continue playing this where you
definitely have chances however against
on play the slow move and now Napo
played rook a to f8 and with the rooks
doubled and the F filed g4 is no longer
possible because now black has a tactic
Queen d5 check and after rook f3 yes you
are threatening mate but now black has
rook captures on g6 that's the problem
because after pawn captures you
eliminate the rook with Czech Queen
captures rook captures and now what
black is just up a piece so after Luke a
to a fait with rook to f3 a nice rook
lifts by by elephant and now King g7 now
again reintroducing the threat of H
captures and g6 Bishop back the h5 and
now Knepper grabs a pawn Queen captures
a native he says you have nothing here
and Geffen tries to trap the Queen rook
the b3 well not to trap the queen but
not allowed the Queen to enter the game
now the threat is rook captures on b7
with check however now I will just show
it even though it's a rapid game and
Griffin was very long time rook the g3
is the crucial line to find here even
though it doesn't give white any
decisive winning idea but it just
creates a whole lot of problems for
black and probably where white should
have gone
or some chances for example a brush-up
characters on g3 now rookie seven check
root blocks rook a to the f7 now you
play Queen captures in g3 with check and
after the root blocks now you play f6
what to check that's the thing you had
to find but you know who would find this
King captures now Queen captures on d6
with check King goes back queenie five
check and now we would most likely see a
repetition here but it's really it's a
really complicated position and uh uh
every move introduces a series of lines
that are possible where you can go wrong
so it's hard to say what could happen
here but here it's most likely a draw
after a queen III checking goes back
when if I've checked King if King to g8
than just a roof yet check you make some
room for your King and with the black
King being so exposed you can't really
lose this as white but you could maybe
win it but okay a Giffen goes for the
different line rugby three goes after
the b7 point and it's a good move
because if b5 or something rook a3
attacks the Queen and threatens rook
captures an a7 which would come with
check and perhaps you could deal some
damage there but nipple goes for rook
captures on f5 he says I'm not
interested in any of that I'm just gonna
play rook f1 and this will result in a
checkmate so rook captures on b7 check
and now King g8 now we have Queen to g4
check rook to g1 was also a possibility
just eliminating any mate ideas because
well Luke 2 F 1 is still am a threat
again and cannot afford a slow move King
h8 you don't have made since the bishop
nicely covers the g7 square but now rook
captures on h7 with King captures and
now bishop g6 check if you start with
the Queen after King to h8 you don't
really have a move here if you if you
check and goes here if you check bishop
blocks and again the main threat is
there and you're just down in material
so after King captures on h7 Bishop g6
check we have King h6 now and here at
Bishop captures on f5 so Gelfand wins
back the material and threatens mate
here
so Neto only one good move for him Queen
back to g8 we have Queens the h3 with
check King Queen to h4 was perhaps a
a bit better because it covers the the
f8f six square which could be very
important for the black king later on
but like I said again extremely low on
time here
King g7 and now rookie for threatening
Ruby g4 check to pick up the Queen King
to f6 and now comes Luke G for attacking
Nepos Queen with Queen to d5 by nipple
and now threatening mate after Queen to
d1 so Luke g6 check King to e7 and now
Queen to h4 with check if you try
something else like Queen to h7 rook f7
just blocks Queen to h4 check Bishop f6
just blocks everything and now you're
gonna have problems if Queen e1 check
you're gonna block with Queen to e5
and if captures you're just gonna
capture back and you get this position
where it's a draw there's no arguing
about that but again fun needs a win he
can't afford to play the best move so
it's just one of those cases
so Queen h4 check from Gelfand King Teti
8 and here again you have to defend
against mate gets on plays Queen to h5
defends mate and also threaten some very
nasty discoveries here so you are Napo
here feel free to pause the video and
try to find the only good move for
nipple in this position while I give you
a couple of seconds so for those of you
who are able to do it congratulations
and finding such a nice slow move with
the King and for those who just want to
enjoy show its King d8 this eliminates
all of White's threats there are no
nasty discoveries here and there are no
useful moves here guess one play the
Queen to g5 check here but it was also
the position where gelfand resigned as
there is nothing well there's nothing
more for white to do here problem is
black can do pretty much anything black
and just block the check and then
deliver mate next move and it's
extremely hard for white to prevent this
if you go back Queen g4 the guard the
mate square just a rocky 8 now you you
have to defend against this mate and
there's really no good way to do it you
can't give your King any breathing space
if you move the Queen then you lose the
bishop if you try h3 then just rook e1
check King h2n Bishop e5 check just wins
on the spot here and now rook h1 is made
and if you don't have to Queen to g5
check if you don't even feel like
calculating what happens after Bishop f6
you just moved the King King c7 and
again White has no ways of continuing
the attack if Queen g4 guarding the
queening square just wrote captures on
f5 and I mean if you capture them its
mate if you don't capture now the route
can also deliver mate you you cannot you
can't really move the bishop as if you
move the bishop then rook to f1 is still
made so after Queen g5 get from the
resigned and with this resignation Boris
Gelfand is out of the feed in Grand Prix
and the nipple advances to the higher
parts of the other tournament so that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it like I
said I was really hoping we will get a
nice game by get fun and we definitely
got a nice game by gelfand you know a
very interesting line a lot of pieces
hanging than Queens hanging then or
everything is just hanging a beautiful
game of hanging Queens if you will so
that's like I said that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Latifah or marks slasher will walk
out Rohan Paula Donna and Matt back with
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot to really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the feeder Grand Prix
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world and don't forget to be a
part of the subscribers video and if
you're interested in joining the chess
team battles and leeches you know do
check out the link in the description
below and my pinned comment so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day